All right, so we've learned that the electric field exerts a force on particles.
If I have an E-field that looks like this and I put a positive charge there,
well, it's going to feel force to the right and a negative charge would feel force to the left.
All right, but how do I know how to draw these lines?
Where did they come from? Where did they go? Let's learn about that. The field line himself.
Well, I mentioned before that electric field is not just felt by charges, it's created by charges.
If I have a positive charge, well the associate electric field will look like this.
The field lines will be evenly spaced and radiating outwards from the charge.
This makes sense because I know if I put a positive charge here,
well it better be repelled from this guy and according to this, it will.
Likewise, a negative charge looks very similar but the field lines point inwards.
Again, this makes sense. I know that a positive charge better be attracted to this negative charge
and according to this electric field line, it will be and a negative charge, if I put it here, will be repelled
since negative charges go opposite the direction of field lines.
Now, knowing what you know about field lines, maybe you can tell me
if I have a positive and a negative charge and they're next to each other,
what would the electric field look like?
I'm going to give you a few options and you pick the best one.
Which of these four options do you think best describes the electric field that exists
when you have two charges, a positive on the left and a negative on the right.
Do you think it's this one?  Do you think maybe there's no electric field.
Do you think it's this one, where there is no electric field
but it bends in this weird way, or maybe this one or that one.
Think about it, think about maybe what would happen if you put a positive
test charge somewhere and what direction you'd expect the force to be?
Good luck. This is a tricky question.